-I'm very happy
to have you here.
It's very nice
to have you in New York.
You and I have
an opposite situation.
I live in New York.
My brother lives in L.A.
You live in L.A.
Your brother lives in New York.
-Right.
-Do you get a chance
to hang out with him?
-I get a chance
every time I come to New York.
This time around, I missed him
cause he's traveling, so...
-Okay.
-So, this time around, I didn't.
-Does he take it personally
that you just chose to come
when he was on the road?
[ Light laughter ]
-I don't know about that, but...
-[ Laughing ] Okay, yeah.
-But it's always nice
to see him.
Always, when I come to New York,
it's like --
we always go out and...
-Does he sort of know how to --
how to treat you
to the best of the city
when you're here?
-He's a connoisseur
of pizza restaurants.
-Oh, that's good.
-You know? And...
-That's the right kind
of connoisseur to be around.
-Yeah, you know, and a --
and a good steak, too.
You know?
-Okay, are you picky with pizza?
'Cause people always ask me
what my favorite pizza is,
and I have to say, "All pizza."
[ Laughter ]
-No, there's --
there's really good pizza.
-Yeah.
-And then there's all pizza.
-Yeah, I think that's fair.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
There's no, like, bad --
I -- I mean --
-Well...
-Yeah,
there's some bad pizza, yeah.
-In L.A.,
-Okay. Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
-I'm so excited that
there is a sequel to "Sicario,"
which was a movie
from a couple years ago
that I absolutely loved.
Were you surprised
that this came back around
to tell more of this story?
-Yeah, a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
You know, the -- the --
the first --
the first movie was, I thought,
a good movie,
and so it had a great group
of filmmakers working on it.
So when they decided to do
this one,
I was a little skeptical
because we were going to have
a new director...
-Mm-hmm.
-...a new
director of photography, so...
But the story that the writer
wrote, Taylor Sheridan,
was very original
and unpredictable
and had a lot of those, like,
"Oh [bleep]" moments...
-Yeah.
-...that -- that --
that I felt when I --
when I read it, I felt like,
"Hey, you know what?
Let's tackle it."
-That's very exciting.
And you must have felt
the character --
the character you played was
so wonderful in the first film.
Do you feel like it changed
to a place
to be interesting
to take it on again?
-Yeah, I think
he evolves quite a bit
in -- in this story,
in the new
"Sicario: Day of the Soldado."
He kind of like --
I like to say he --
You know, in the first one,
we meet him,
and he's like a hit man
and a heartless, one-track mind
kind of guy bent on revenge.
And in this one,
I think that --
It's through his journey,
I think, we find out that he --
he's rehabilitated to an extent.
He's not innocent,
but he's rehabilitated
through this relationship
that he has
with this young girl
called Isabela
played by Isabela Moner.
Yeah.
-That's really exciting.
I can't wait to see it.
I've -- Like I said,
I loved the first one.
I also want to ask,
in recent years,
"Guardians of the Galaxy,"
"Avengers," "Star Wars" --
are those exciting movies
to be a part of?
Were those
the kind of movies that,
if you were a kid,
you would have enjoyed?
-Yeah. What do you -- Yeah.
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
I mean, that's the way I feel.
Yeah.
[ Light laughter ]
-Big time. Big time.
It's like -- It's like
going back to the future.
-Yeah.
-And I'm very lucky that
"Star Wars" called.
You know, the director
Rian Johnson on "The Last Jedi,"
he called me up,
and I said, "Yeah, no problem."
And so did James Gunn,
when he called me up to play
The Collector
in "Guardians of the Galaxy,"
so that's a --
you know, that's a --
that's an actor's dream.
-Yeah.
-You know? Yeah.
-Just the call. Any call.
-Just any call. Any call.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. I remember, as an actor,
if your phone rings
and it's not, like,
the bill collector,
you're like,
"This is a good day."
[ Laughter ]
-It's a good day, for sure.
-So, I know,
on probably all these projects,
scripts are like
tightly guarded secrets,
and for "Star Wars,"
is it true that
they had to bring a tablet
to your house,
and someone had to wait outside
while you read it?
-Yeah. They bring --
They bring, like, an iPad
with -- with the code
and the whole bit,
and the script is right there,
and it was really --
I'm a slow reader, you know?
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-It -- You know, usually,
it could take me 8, 10 hours
to really read a script.
-Uh-huh.
-I mean, I can read it.
-I feel like you take
some breaks, yeah.
-Yeah, you know, of course I do.
I daydream quite a bit.
-Uh-huh.
-I digress.
[ Laughter ]
But -- But, you know,
a "Star Wars" script --
it's -- it's got
a lot of weird names and...
-Yeah, that makes sense.
-...it's like a new language,
and so it took a long time.
So, that guy --
that poor guy was waiting
for, I'd say, about 8 hours.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. You know?
-Did you give him
a chair or anything?
Was he sitting in a car?
What was he doing?
-Well, um...
Uh, no, I didn't.
[ Laughter ]
I-I kind of forgot
that he was there.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, no, that's --
-It's terrible.
They say that's one of
the side effects of daydreaming.
[ Light laughter ]
-You forget where you are
or who you are.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Yeah.
-You have a --
You have a 7-year-old daughter.
-Yes, I do. Yeah.
-Does she --
Are -- Are these movies --
Do they appeal to her,
your movies,
or what are the movies
she's into?
-Well, she really loves,
you know, the --
the "Star Wars" --
she likes the "Star Wars" movie
that I've done.
I mean, of course, she's not
going to be able to see
"Sicario: Day of the Soldado"
for the next 10 years.
-Right, yeah.
Well, not until she saw
the first "Sicario,"
or else it won't make sense.
-Right, right. Exactly, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Totally.
-Yeah.
-But you know what movie
she really loves?
And it -- She's a big fan
of Josh Brolin in "The Goonies."
-Ooh, "Goonies." Sure.
-"Goonies." Yeah.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, it --
it's really funny 'cause...
-So, has she met Josh?
-She hasn't.
-Okay, gotcha.
-But -- But she will,
but she might be surprised
when she sees him.
But I don't think he's changed
that much.
-Yeah, we actually --
we have side-by-sides
of -- of modern-day Brolin
and "Goonies" Brolin.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, the same-sized skull,
you know?
-Yeah. He does have a big head.
-Big head.
He does have a big head.
Yeah.
-You've worked with him
up close and personal.
-I've worked with him
on five projects.
-Five movies?
-Yeah.
-Two "Sicarios."
What are the -- What else?
-"The Avengers."
-Right. Of course.
-"Inherent Vice"...
Paul Thomas Anderson
and with Joaquin Phoenix.
And what else did I do?
I did a TV show
early on in my career.
I was 20, probably,
and he was the lead --
it was called "Private Eye."
-Okay.
-I guest-starred on a TV show.
-Gotcha.
-And he --
that's where I met him.
-Oh, that's fant--
-So, yeah.
-And did --
And when you worked together,
'cause I guess then it was
probably at least a decade
before
you worked together again,
did he remember you
from "Private Eye"?
-I hope he did.
[ Laughter ]
I never asked, but, yeah.
I think he did.
I think he did, yeah.